it's
uh a better regulation of uh advertising
uh reparability becomes the norm and uh
labeling is is better regulated we know
that some of the obstacles are still
there but on a whole on the whole the
text does strengthen our requirements
and companies need to play the game by
having reasonable prices and to make it
uh uh uh make information available as
to the availability of spare parts when
items are purchased and uh the EU does
need to set the example here our
citizens have uh Great Hopes placed in
us and there rightly uh people's
confidence in Brussels has been highly
uh diminished among in many sectors and
uh let us not just open our mouths to
yawn but to make progress thank
you thank you very much the floor now
goes to Madame rova on behalf of the
unlined members thank you very much Mr
chair colleagues
colleagues we keep talking about the
green economy how excellent this is for
the environment and this seems to be a
mantra of sorts I'm glad that we are now
dealing with the protection of the
consumer the final beneficiary who uses
these products and I would like to very
much thank Madame borzan for an
excellent report we cannot expect
everything would be Echo bio row a
mantra that is being abused uh by many
companies in their commercial leaflets
and production campaigns they also
mislead consumers in convincing them to
buy products that seem to be of better
quality that seem to be of a a more
responsible approach to the environment
I'm glad that this cannot be abused
anymore and it has to be substantiated
if a product claims to be better for the
environment it has to be proven and we
will also focus on a better use of these
products not to um uh keep buying more
and more products but to keep using the
same product for a longer period of time
I also believe that the objective that
keeps to be that are being now discussed
is that uh a 30-month for implementation
is a suff efficient time even for the
producers to deal with this thank you
Madame
raor thank you and now allow me to ask
Mr Schwab um one and a half
minute president
colleagues we want a competitive
internal Market an internal Market that
gives consumers the choice between the
best products and the goal is to ensure
that suppliers provide the best Goods
we dealt with this issue in the digital
internal Market a few months ago and now
we want to make sure that consumers can
trust what they're told about different
products I mean I think it is legitimate
to Market your products but uh you can
you should only be able to do so with
statements that can be monitored so
statements such as environmentally
positive or climate neutral will in the
future be subject to checks and that's a
good thing because we want to ensure
that uh the circular economy acts
appropriately we don't simply want it to
be a way to sell
products there's also this issue of
planned obsolesence but uh there's not
really any evidence about that so
efforts to deal with that seem to be
perhaps inappropriate I mean colleagues
colleague uh Europe needs to provide
consumers as well as businesses with the
best possible internal market and this
proposal aims to improve that so
congratulations to all who' worked on
this
proposal now allow me to ask Madame shal
Mo the floor is
yours the consumers of Europe can play
an important role in the green
transition we can V vote with our feet
and vote with our wallets but for that
to work we need to know the truth about
the products that we buy we have to be
able to trust the information that the
consumer gives us and we need to be able
to understand it but at the moment It's
a Jungle all sorts of things are claimed
to be climate neutral Co neutral and so
on clothes food whatever it's important
it's impossible to understand as
consumer but we're ending that now it is
this is the end of undocumented green
claims in the future The Producers can
only use green claims if they have
actual proof of it and we can also get
rid of the other bad habits which
mislead the consumers and lead to
increased uh uh consumption so thank you
very much you've done excellent
work thank you very much the floor now
goes to Mr
B thank you uh vice president
commissioner reinders dear colleagues
protecting consumers is one of our
priorities in the inco committee and
this report only makes sure that the
consumers will be properly informed and
that that they will not be misled into
buying products which claim to be
environmental friendly without this uh
statement being true it is important
that uh the consumers who choose
products that protect the environment
are not misled by um misleading
commercials it is important to have
clear standards for a product to be
called environmental friendly and one
Criterion is not enough the whole
economy will be involved in reaching the
goals of the green deal however they
have to do it in an honest Manner and
our consumers from our countries must be
able to to make informed choices this is
the only way in which they can influence
the market uh in the right direction
thank you and I wish you full success
with your report Mrs
Boran
okay
colleagues in the EU there are more and
more so-called climate neutral green and
sustainable products and that shows how
much demand there is from consumers
people want to shop
sustainably three out of four EU
consumers say that it's important to
them the effect that their product has
on the
environment and we need to make it
possible for these consumers to make
appropriate choices this purchasing
power needs to be directed towards
sustainable business businesses and
sustainable products and we can't have
consumers being deceived when these
claims are
made tomorrow's vote will clearly show
that greenwashing is not acceptable no
clothes no Cosmetics no cars or no World
Cup football World Cup can be called
climate neutral if it's
not so this is
important it's important to be able to
be environmentally friendly but you have
to be able to prove that you are you
can't simply claim it claim it so we're
going to ensure that sustainable
products are genuinely sustainable thank
you now allow me to ask Mr belan to
speak the floor is yours Mr commissioner
today we discuss a proposal pivotal to
empowering consumers in the European
Union and fight against unfair
commercial practices this initiative
significantly enhances transparency
around product sustainability guiding
consumers toward choices with detailed
information on durability and
reparability it balances regulatory
measures with Market dynamism fostering
Innovation for our European companies
importantly The Proposal Embraces a
voluntary guarantee mechanism promoting
legal Frameworks that strengthen market
operations without imposing obligations
we are not enforcing the green deal
instead we are making it attractive and
beneficial for companies and consumers
lastly the inclusion of riew clause
proposed by my my political group
reflects our foresight it's crucial to
assess digital service and software
regulations ensuring they are neither
overly burdensome nor unnecessary I
believe this Clause will safeguard the
digital development from being stifled
fostering a balance between en
environmental goals and technological
progress thank
you thank you very much allow me now to
ask Madame B the floor is
yours thank you president commissioner
when we talk about ecology in Parliament
we always say the same thing impose a
policy from brussles is never something
that is subject to an impact
assessment when companies are subject to
your constraints the people who suffer
are the consumers and obviously the
competitors in third countries benefit
because they can then replace European
Goods with cut pric Goods produced
without any considerations after Decades
of looking towards free trade across
borders we need to have a new
policy we can see that the failure of
your policy you've now transferred
Europe into something into a continent
that doesn't produce so listen to us we
want an economic policy based on local
production and Common Sense thank
you thank you very much and now the
floor goes to Mr
pabl thank you very much president
commissioner the way uh of approaching
Life by just producing using and
throwing things away is not applicable
anymore uh citizens have a right today
to participate in the economy for
example through the rule of the three uh
sevens sorry the seven RS recycling
reusing Etc but if they to be able to do
that they need to have uh reliable in
and truthful information about the goods
that they purchasing uh such practices
as
greenwashing are aimed at uh fooling at
uh deceiving consumers by giving them
false information uh and there are
companies that present themselves as uh
having uh environmental friendly
environmentally friendly uh products but
they can't prove it or that simply not
so so with this text we are uh aiming to
ensure that uh consumers can make
decisions on a well-informed basis and
this is to provide legal certainty to
the company and to Consumers we want a
EU that's in line with our values and
our principles striking a harmonious
balance between the consumer interests
and the environment and without
sacrificing competitiveness of our
companies thank
you
president president commissioner
colleagues our
economic model is one that constantly
requires more products at cheaper prices
our planet can no longer sustain that
and our growth is not sustainable and
that's why we need nothing less than
a
reconstruction of our economic model we
need to buy products that are
sustainable and have a long life and
they need to be
provided we've done that with the
ecodesign legislation
and now we're moving on to ensuring that
consumers know what they're buying they
shouldn't be
deceived consumers must now have genuine
rights the right to
repair so that they can obtain redress
from
manufacturers and so that they can
ensure that products aren't made
difficult to repair there need to be
incentives for consumers to to get Goods
repaired rather than simply buying a new
one so consumers need to be empowered
that's what we're going to be voting on
here we need to ensure that consumers
have a right to repair thank
you allow me to ask Mr KES to speak the
floor is
yours thank you president commissioner
any progress in defending consumers is
good news and so this draft directive is
an excellent piece of news because it
will protect consumers from uh being
fooled and deceived uh fooled or
deceived when it comes to the quality of
products and the nature of the products
and it also U defends uh the interests
of those producers that are acting
loyally and uh behaving as they should
but let us not be fooled
here one sometimes make deliberate
decisions when my mother bought a fridge
that was going to last for 20 years she
wasn't presenting this as a green
decision she was buying a well-made
fridge but today there are people that
want to fool the consumers with
misleading descriptions that's a that's
a that's a deliberate decision so it's
all very well trying to empower
consumers but let us also do something
else that we can do which is to ensure
uh uh protection of consumers not just
through legislation which is very
important but also implementation of
legislation with
inspections uh to uh act against those
who make who do business out of
deceiving
consumers I don't see Madame K and the
next speaker is Mr
n president colleagues now in order to
defend European consumers we need a
strong Europe which can compete in
global markets China for example is
developing new models in World Market
markets now we need to ensure that the
green transition is appropriately
legislated for and we need to ensure a
pragmatic and realistic approach to
dealing with climate
change C consumers shouldn't simply be
considered users who are subject to the
costs of stringent green policies Europe
needs to try and develop an economy that
is based on the requirements of families
and workers because we can't forget the
important that Europe and member states
has had during recent decades in
promoting economic growth and also
ensuring emancipation for human beings
right across the world we have a model
that provides social protection for
consumers and this is something that is
unprecedented in the world this is what
consumers await from Europe thank
you thank you and I I now ask colleague
Le
mares president commissioner if we were
all to choose the most environmentally
friendly product available if we were to
decide to repair it rather than
replacing it we would be making a
contribution to this uh to a sustainable
defense of uh the environment by uh uh
acting in the market but without
reliable information on the product we
can't do this if people are trying to
make things uh look green when they're
not green if we're not given information
on the products if we're not told where
we can repair them uh where the spare
parts will be available it's no good and
the rules being put forward by the uh EU
are aimed at that end to ensure that the
consumers will have the necessary
information and then we'll know uh where
and how uh something can be repaired and
if there are spare parts or not and and
this will also benefit the uh uh Pockets
the budgets of our families so dear
colleagues uh this uh climatic
transition is not just a matter of uh
empowering uh Us in the EU and our
citizens it's really important to uh
make this incumbent upon all of our uh
citizens and our producers and companies
thank
you and now the floor goes to Mr for one
minute thank you very much commissioner
this proposal will hopefully finally
make sure that European citizens will
not be misled by false information about
products and services today more or less
everything that has some kind of a green
label is packaged in eco-friendly paper
and it claims that it's been
manufactured
ecologically reality however is very
often very different looking at the
entire life cycle of products we very
often find out that this is all a fraud
that people are forced to pay lots of
extra money uh I've proposed many
amendments to this uh proposal and I beg
everyone to adopt them mainly because we
don't want to get to a point where like
in the Dual quality of food stuffs that
some companies offer ecological products
in some member states while the other
member states become the trash bin for
everything else thank
you thank you very much and now the
floor goes to colleague Angel
commissioner and colleagues consumers
and their choices they play a central
role in the green transition and also in
boosting this circular economy and
indeed many want to consume more
sustainably however in many ways the
odds have been against them a
bewildering Jungle of labels and dubious
environmental claims products designed
to have a limited lifespan or a lack of
information about the reparability of
products have meant that commun
consumers have found it difficult to
make Greener choices and contribute
meaningfully to the green transition we
as the Socialist and Democrats have long
advocated measures to counter such
unfair commercial practices and this
directive is a GameChanger it will for
example strengthen the credibility
transparency and monitoring of labels to
avoid green and social washing it
equally proposes strong measures to
tackle early obsolescence and provides
more information to Consumers about
their rights under the legal guarantee
of products with this directive we
Empower Europeans to choose products
that are more durable repairable and
sustainable it is emblematic of how our
European Union can benefit Europeans in
their everyday life thank you to the
reporter and the shadow reporters for
the good work thank you very
much thank you uh and uh now I would
like to ask the colleague kbra Ken the
floor is
yours president
commission
colleagues and people listening to us I
think we have to take this very
seriously to use the markets and the
powers of consumers is one of the best
ways of influence situation but that
does mean that the consumers have to
have the tools consumers want to take
their responsibility but it can be very
different something which might be good
for one element of the the environment
might be worse for another part of the
environment and so you have to be able
to rely on the information you're given
it's not okay to mislead the consumer if
something is supposed to be sustainable
then it must be sustainable in reality
in that way we're strengthening the
power of the consumer and strengthening
the power of the markets in the interest
of the green transition that's how we
get a good result
the welcome to the
parliament thank you so
much
well ladies and gentlemen uh consumers
are worried about the environment and
they often carry out their purchases on
the basis of labels that promise that
things are recyclable sustainable Etc
but actually 78% of citizens in Europe
believe that uh businesses are involved
in greenwashing and the truth is that
half of businesses are greenwashing and
that's why the parliament as a result of
the excellent work carried out by my
colleague Mrs bouran has crafted this
leg legislation that will enable us to
do a away with planned obsolesence first
and foremost by extending the life of
products and secondly doing away with
products that deceive
consumers such uh as uh
presenting software updates as necessary
before they actually are and also
dealing with ink for printers so we
have worked on this and now we're
working on legislation on green claims
the idea is to ensure that our
businesses can reduce their
environmental impact and also to fight
greenwashing thank
you thank you and we'll now follow with
the kdi five MEPS have asked for the
floor so everybody will get the floor
and the first to speak is uh colle
glak h
thank you president dear colleagues the
good thing is that the citizens will no
longer have to ask themselves or to
doubt uh the truthfulness of what is
being marketed to us and that we are
going to put an end to the um unfair
practices we're talking about the green
transition it is a cultural change as
consumers our choices from the small
everyday decisions to the large invest
ments affect the environment empowering
consumers uh requires us to provide the
consumers with the right correct
information which will help them to make
sustainable decisions in Croatia and
throughout the European Union we see
that consumers uh want to buy
eco-friendly uh products they need to
know where they these products have come
from uh about their environmental
footprint where they have been produced
and so on
consumers not only want to have
sustainable options but they want to
support uh the green transition with
their money transparency and The
credibility of labels but we also are
one thing that we need but we also need
to have the balance between protecting
consumers and protecting producers thank
you
and uh thank you president uh
commissioner colleagues happy New Year
uh we can't have a green transition
without consumers being fully empowered
as the effects of climate change become
more real and deadly consumers are
demanding to make empowered choices
green products sustainable practices and
ethical sourcing are what a new
generation of consumers want and yet we
actually make it more difficult for
consumers to make these types of
informed choices greenwashing and its
consequences are a Scourge for too long
manufacturers have been able to claim
that their product is sustainable or
ethically sourced without requiring
proof this new legislation is a clear
sign of action that the EU uh is
prepared to give consumers proper
information now consumers can rely on
clear labeling generic environmental
labels such as biodegradable
eco-friendly and climate neutral will be
prohibited consumers will now have to be
informed which products are more durable
and reparable and real consequences for
Traders and companies which do not abide
by these laws
to achieve a truly sustainable economy
we must Empower consumers thank
you and now Mr Wallace you have the
floor climate neutrality claims based on
offsetting are a massive contributor to
climate mitigation deterrence climate
claims or products based on carbon
offsetting will now based on the
parliament's work be added to the list
of unfair commercial practices this ban
is limited to products it doesn't cover
companywide claims but it's still
significant
these changes are also currently
impacting the ongoing negotiations for
the green claims directive and the
carbon removal certification framework
the empowering consumers directive is
now an important back stop for future
anti-g greenwashing policy these there
claims to be a new found appetite to
tackle offsetting if not in the
commission then certainly in the
Parliament and arguably also in the
council we need to build on this and
take the next logical step which is to
contest climate neutrality and Net Zero
as climate Concepts and as the basis for
EU climate policy establishing a
separate EU carbon removal Target is key
to
this thank you very much and Mr sakol
you have the
floor
yeah
thank you I was sure that this law uh
will put an end to inbuilt defects uh
practice but instead of preventing uh
those products from being placed on the
market only the advertising is
prohibited whereas um producing them and
selling them is not considered as such
so we will still have such products uh
on our shelves as Madame pelier has said
fortunately we have the Eco design law
which was agreed in December which
specified that the Ecco design
regulations must ensure that that there
is no premature
obsolesence and uh the uh directive on
unfair business practices will have to
be amended uh to prevent um different
qualities of products put on the market
in different States unfortunately this
was not done so we still have work to
do miss Dale you have the floor um I
think you can't really go into a shop
nowadays without everything you see
being marketed as climate neutral
whether it's a pair of runners or a
bunch of bananas people are constantly
bombarded by these generic claims which
actually don't mean anything we even
have Airlines selling carbon neutral
flights I mean the idea of this this has
made a joke of the whole idea of
conscious consumption and have led
Shoppers into believing that they're
being coded and they are because generic
environmental claims are inherently
misleading because they aren't based on
any standardized environmental
performance they're often even
specifically designed with a view to Cod
and uh intentionally fool uh The Shopper
so with this new legislation and really
thanks to the efforts of the parliament
companies can no longer claim claim that
their products are climate neutral
eco-friendly or green carbon offsetting
and calling them carbon neutral flights
will also be outplay this is a really
important step forward and fair play to
the parliament team for driving it
forward thank you and I give the floor
to the commissioner
Rangers thank you president um dear
members of parliament I want to thank
thank you for the debate that we've had
and for your support for this draft
directive but especially for all of the
work that's been done by Parliament and
uh uh notably by the rapporteur uh in
the framework of uh the rest of the work
this is going to make it possible to
empower our consumers to have more
information and act in favor of the
green transition this is actually a key
stage when it comes to enabling our
consumers to make decisions for more
durable for more sustainable form of
consumption so this is an essential text
to ensure that companies are subject to
uh rules that are more harmonized across
the EU more particularly with regard to
uh green claims uh and green washing as
has been mentioned in the debate the
commission is prepared to do everything
necessary to uh facilitate transposal of
this new text so that it can be applied
soonest and uh properly and I'd like to
thank you again again for your uh
attention and for your support for this
uh very significant text thank
you and now uh I give the floor to
colleague borzan to conclude the debate
on this
item I would like to thank all those who
have taken part in our
debate I would like to thank you for
your kind words of support the process
has not been easy has not been simple
but as the commissioner has
said our approach was highly ambitious
and uh the end result is a a better life
for our
citizens the responsibility for a fair
market must not uh be a burden on the
citizens on the
individuals this responsibility lies on
the big players on this market and uh
the goal and interest of all of us uh
must be to improve the lives of our
citizens and the new rules are designed
to do just that thank
you thank you very much uh this
concludes the debate and the voting will
be
tomorrow the next item on the agenda is
uh transparency and accountability of
non-governmental organizations funded
from the EU budget uh report by
micher the raor has the
floor well